what's up reject nation it is I John
Humphrey coming at you and with me today
joining me as my excellent friend we
actually went to college together wow
this is Bryn was Nikki is that what you
do go by your name maybe what I bring
Nicole oh my god by Renoir's Nikki all
right I don't want to get you wrong I
feel like such a great friend there's
such great friends it's like we just met
five minutes ago and he's like thank you
for answering my Craigslist ad it's
gonna be a great video you are going to
pay me and cat food after this right
it's a trade video for the fridge
already waiting for you but you have to
feed our cats in order to take it it's
like the fee and we did go to college
together so shout out to going to
college shouts out to Nate Thomas and
hey it paid off cuz you just made a
movie I did I should tell the people
what's it is called her side of the bed
but you can probably sum it up more
succinctly than I her side of the bed
it's a romantic dramedy it is about two
best friends who share an intimate night
and then their friendship is forever
changed it will make you laugh if you're
really sensitive
it might make you cry it was a labor of
love truly independent and now it's on
Amazon and distributed overseas and
stuff that's that's cool
go check that shiznit out stream it by
Adi of their DVDs there's DVD ya buy a
DVD hold it your hey and hey you know
what else is a story about a you know
two friends who share an intimate night
and are forever changed
venom is is just exactly like that I
mean we are we are as well hey man I I
still have a voicemail from you from
like really late at night after I was
getting off the universal one that's the
story for another oh my god you have to
play that for me that's into this video
and to these guys that they have have
you seen a hissy before how it should
have ended no these are strapped in this
is gonna be a black here we go
we read both of your arms did with your
legs and read your face right off your
head and it will be this ladies on the
street what does that even mean
nobody says turd in the wind did you
mean leaf in the wind no tell us you've
never seen a turd blowing in the wind no
that's that's not really a thing
I mean maybe at the zoo if the monkey
throws his poop yes see like that nobody
says that you will eat your arms and all
that is and no one will find your torso
until the pigs you did it again what the
saying yes you did
he did didn't he you're dead it is when
pigs fly or when hell freezes over we do
not understand that you do not get off
phrases this is not rocket surgery do
not beat a dead horse in the mouth wow I
think maybe just stop talking I would be
much more terrified if you weren't
talking oh no no you opened this can of
worms
[Music]
I heard the new spider-man died so I
thought I'd just put it out there I'm
available now spider-man we will burn
that bridge when we get to it I think
you meant cross that bridge when we get
to it no we meant burn it not bad as a
compact one but I very much appreciated
that actually I've never seen them do
one for just a trailer this was kind of
magical because like that one line
caused such a disturbance well I mean
when when I first heard the line I was
also like gonna back yeah it's in all of
these comic everywhere every panel he
says his catchphrases there's a venom
sitcom everyone would go crazy when he
says the turd line yeah it would have to
be like either very strong gust of wind
or a very light turn very brittle turd
yeah maybe like a Chicago wind and it's
like hold to the turd is hard and then
it just kind of picks up what kind of
storm is it - I mean you know if it's a
[ __ ] storm how are you gonna tell which
turd is you I can't tell where I end in
another term every day of my life which
you know maybe it's like that for for
venom when you come from you know just
one reserve of primordial alien goo you
know you just split apart making up
friends you know you ever make another
symbiote character and you're just like
that's my old arm or something I don't
know this video tickled me I think the
part of it is I'm just a fan of that
improv game of I guess it's not really
tops but just you know they pulled out
like every bad you know equivalent to a
turn of phrase yes beautiful I don't
know I really wish this was what the
movie was like it might be you know
maybe the trailer didn't didn't give
away all the
idioms they messed with venom is gonna
be a banter based car I do have a good
idiom like a good turn of phrase cuz you
wonder where it came from and then just
to hear them so many back to back and
then mashed up yeah I'm all for one I
hate like those things don't translate
to other countries that language is so
like of course of course
venom is gonna get some of them wrong
cuz they're from outer space yeah like
you know they came here on a meteor and
hitched a ride on spider-man nah not not
in this universe though I was like yeah
we don't know it's unclear Sony seems
like they really want it to be in the
Marvel cannon but Marvel is like you had
to make a venom movie what would it what
was your venom be weird
what would my venom me yeah cuz nowadays
like everyone's getting to do to take a
turn the superhero game they're trying
to find more female filmmakers and stuff
if you got the opportunity what you do
like what would if I had my own
superhero or like specific if they gave
you this property this property Tom
Hardy yeah Tom Hardy and RZA met at your
disposal go don't ask me what I would do
with them cuz it has nothing to do with
them it would just be an all-male remake
of your film her side of the bed yes
absolutely
hardy and RISM two best friends share an
intimate night Tom Hardy and RZA med and
then their friendship is forever changed
wouldn't that be a great movie that
absolutely that would be a tremendous
move because I feel like one of those
directors who like abuses his or her
power do you know what I mean because
like it would just be like a fantasy
that I'm creating for myself that would
be no narrative it would just be a bunch
of like boudoir sequences okay no kids
from what I've seen of this trailer it
looks really good I'm not su as we
discuss I'm not super deep into the Marv
I got something for you please do I'm
laughs really quick
and all the venoms lived happily ever
after that's like a turd you know I feel
like a turd is usually in toilet maybe
discarded hopefully a turd is in the
toilet
ya know I've seen a lot of turds on the
street and I don't know if they're dog
turds or human turns but I feel like the
receipts something even bordering on a
human turd in the street I feel like a
really Drive yes no you're fine it's
just exactly what you think it is but
what I'm saying is a turd and the wind
seems like how it turned live happily
ever after because it's just like don't
want to fly yeah
yeah just like in that Sugar Ray song I
think so yeah like a wicked winter by a
week you bought a her side of the bed is
out on DVD and streaming yeah right now
you guys can go check it out it's not
even a trailer like this video it's a
full movie it's like like really
happened it's a lot like venom it's it's
about a symbiotic relationship I mean I
want to be in a symbiotic relationship
with Tom Hardy you should be cuz you'll
get to like kick a lot of asses and eat
heads and and you know also be Tom Hardy
yeah do like open up my face a little
bit and his face is underneath there we
always the problem is how would you
crash your name's together that's the
hard part cuz you know you can't be like
ROM ROM hard was braum hard woz is
actually pretty great name her side of
the bed written and directed by Braun
Hardwick is available work for can
people check that shiz out it is on
Amazon you can buy the DVD if you like
to hold things in your hand if you have
Prime it you can don't a prime you can
buy it or rent it you got a friend
watching describe it to you you get
after it that way you could have a
friend watch it and have them draw scene
by scene what happens and then present
it to you much like this oh that's I
want the her size bed graphic novel
that's what I want and I also want y'all
to subscribe to how it should have ended
that's more important but also subscribe
to the real rejects click
notification bell ring it ding it toll
it whatever you want to do to the Bell
do that because it does what the
subscribe-button ought to do and you can
check us out on patreon we got
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is a great community a lot of exclusive
content would love to have you become a
patron ejected a piece out